say some things
okay well let's see for people who are
joining this live stream i sign myself
up to try and talk a little bit about
how to write expositions as
computational essays
and we have several people here who have
written lots of stuff
and i've written lots of stuff myself
and i think what i signed up to do was
to maybe critique
some of what some other people have
written
and i i think the last time we tried to
do one of these
not as a live stream and i realized i
was doing a terrible critique
of things that were written by somebody
now
and i thought at the very least let me
go and critique things that i myself
wrote a long time ago so i found stuff
on the web that i wrote when i was like
12 or 13 years old
um and we could critique some of that
um it was kind of fun to critique but um
uh maybe we should go to that was before
computational essays they
were had not been inve would not be
invented for another few decades after
that
um all right let's go let's go and look
at some of the things that have been
provided here
all right let me so we have one about
fourier series
i see eric is an experienced writer here
i'm not sure that this is going to be as
useful
as um uh i think i looked at this one
before didn't i
has this been changed since the last
time or not
uh not much on that section now
okay so i'm going to critique this
immediately i mean
that well i think you changed a bunch of
things here but the first point is
like what on earth are we talking about
here
right you've got to have some
introduction that just is saying
um i mean it's good to jump into this
uh
yeah you see you've got a show here for
the typical person
okay unfortunately it's a little bit
tricky right i mean you've got you've
got to show this
um how do you show this you would say
see i this is kind of ugly to have to do
something like this
oh gosh um
no i'm sorry this is you know look what
you should start with
is just to say we are going to look at
what happens
when you nestedly apply a function
okay and then we've got a particular
function
let's consider when and
and maybe even although i hate to say it
you say
f of x blank colon equals this thing
might be useful
but you've got multiple kind of
conceptual things going on with the
width here why do you have the width
here
you don't need the width here you can
just say just get rid of the width
and just say 1.5 here
and just say what does that do okay
you don't you don't well okay you can
say it approaches point three all right
fine
um that's pretty obvious what's gonna
happen there but it's okay to show that
um oh i'm sorry it's very small
yes um
you see there's more drama here the fact
that it does something really wild here
is drama
there's you know if i was writing this
what i would do is i would have some
kind of build up here
of oh it goes to a fixed point okay fine
in fact my first example might be
having it go to a limit cycle just
because that's not hard to understand
but yet it's a bit more exciting it's
like well you know somebody might look
at this and they might say it's obvious
any iteration of a function must go to a
fixed point
am i making sense
the one part i wouldn't like in this
moment that we mix mathematics with
numerics with machine numerics and the
normal person has no
no intuition virtue which is which
that's that's true too i mean you've got
to you know
one challenge here is um
you know can people understand this idea
of nesting functions
you know i suppose i don't know how
intuitive that is
that's certainly you know i mean
certainly when i
show that particular thing you can do
something like this
oops you can do something like this um
but i'm not sure that really helps
because then going from that
i think that's actually super confusing
then probably to go from that making a
frame around something to doing
something with a numerical value
um but
uh i mean what was your point michael
that the people that going from
something like this to going something
to something with numbers
was confusing no my point is like you
show here a list of numbers they are
correct
if the list would be 10 elements more
they would be formed
because of we mix machine arithmetic
with
mathematics sure
see that's in a category i mean you know
i have certain principles of
expositional writing
you know uh as people who work with me
have heard before my zeroth principle of
expositional writing is
um that uh if you don't understand what
you're writing about your readers don't
stand a chance
this is another principle which is
you've got to know
several you know a significant distance
ahead
of what you're trying to of the
exposition level you're trying to
achieve
in other words when somebody writes
something you know
i'm you know if i'm trying to explain
something i know
when i'm getting close to the limit of
what i understand so to speak
and one has to be sort of super careful
there and so
in a case like this eliding the point
that michael is making about machine
precision versus arbitrary precision and
so on
just not having to address that question
is
a good thing but understanding that
there is such a
you know an elephant lurking in the
corner of the room
is important i mean in other words in
other words if you were
a place where i always get nervous
writing expositional things
is when i know i'm very close to the
edge of what i understand
because if you're close to the edge of
what you understand
it's very easy to end up saying
something that is
technically wrong so to speak because
there was something from just over the
divide what you don't understand
that that is going to come and bite you
whereas if you're still
far within what you understand you can
be pretty pretty sure that
even though you say things informally
it's less like people are obsessed
sometimes with you know when they write
expositions
they're obsessed with you can't say
centrifugal force
let's say really why not you know oh
long explanation about some formal thing
about definition of force etc etc etc
that's perhaps a bad example but you
know it's like
don't worry i'm not going to get myself
in trouble because i do think i
understand the bigger picture of what's
going on
and it's it's some you know people
people sometimes get obsessed with this
you know
you've got to say the precise thing
because there
but so long as you understand a fair
distance beyond the exposition you're
giving it's not really such a problem
because you can make sure
that nothing you say so there's some
things where you could say it
and then because you made that imprecise
statement
you know you tangle yourself up and some
other issue and um
and then you're kind of toast but but if
you if you kind of know what you're
doing
you can avoid that um
yeah so i see on our on our live stream
is commenting that every computational
essay would start with the central
result
i agree giving people a roadmap of where
you're going
is very important like for example let's
take fourier series
okay so i'm going to criticize this
sorry eric
um is eric here yeah i
i gave you more than i knew you wanted
so that you can throw some out
okay well here the the okay
the question is who is the audience here
you know so if i was going to explain
fourier series
so the question is at what level
is the person you're explaining it to by
the time they understand
orthogonality relationships they
probably already know about fourier
series
and and this is you know by the time
they understand orthogonality of
functions
fourier series are example number one of
that
so even using that word
kind of already zeros out your audience
because you know now there's a different
um uh
you know there's a different use for
documents which are refresher documents
that is
the person you know for me sometimes
i'll be like i more or less understand
this but i need a refresher on what the
definition is
that's a somewhat different thing but so
let's talk about how would we explain
fourier series and who is our audience
so let's say
okay we can assume
that if we're going to explain fourier
series with formulas and all that kind
of thing
that okay so let's let's assume we're
heading for
i don't know the the school system well
enough but maybe
the pre-calculus crowd okay
so they okay first question is do they
know trigonometry
do they know what sines and cosines are
okay
one question is can we get there from
here if they don't know what sines and
cosines are can we still explain fourier
series
or are we up a creek without a paddle
what do people think
my question would be why would we want
to do this
i feel like like the audience that
has heard this or is currently studying
it is probably a much more attentive
audience
than an audience for which this is four
years in the future
fair point okay so let me make another
ask
the question at the beginning who is the
audience and i think we're still
answering that question
right but i want to i want to address
what michael is saying okay
so you know there's ways people
understand things
right and some people
are better at buffering
non-understanding than others
for example i'm not very good at that if
i'm trying to understand something
and there's a a step that i just don't
get
it's very hard for me to go on past that
and
i mean i can you know sometimes i can go
on past that as sort of intuitive
swinging through the the upper levels of
the jungle type
type level but if i really want to
you know really understand it and be
able to reason about it if there's a
step i don't understand i'm toast at
that point
other people have an easier time getting
through things where there's parts they
don't understand
and i think you know one of the things
that eric
did with mathworld then copied by
wikipedia and so on
is this kind of you know tell it as it
is which i which i think
you know uh sort of very direct writing
which people had tended not to do for
things like math before that
and um uh so now that i'm criticizing
eric here
but but no what am i trying to say the
the thing i'm trying to say
in response to michael is yes you're
right
that the people who are really studying
fourier series will understand more
stuff
but what if they managed to get through
i mean this is the thing you talk to
people they say
i did my calculus class i got an a in my
calculus class
oh can you understand what
you know a function of a function is uh
uh you know so in other words
they didn't get it they they thought
they got it to the point where they
could get an a in the class
i was i was just seeing something
yesterday talking about
the the the sort of uh the number
sense and whether whether humans are
unique among animals and understanding
the idea of numbers
and the point was being made that yes
you can teach a chimpanzee
to go point at things but that doesn't
mean that they necessarily have the idea
of numbers so to speak
and i think you know this is the
question are you i tend to feel
like the extent to which you can go back
to basics and explain things from
something very very basic
is is worthwhile now some people you
know a phenomenon that i think has
changed over the years
is if you if this started off with
something that is seems like it's a very
basic explanation of what sine and
cosine are
you might say that's going to lose a big
part of the market
because people are going to say this is
too elementary well if they can visually
look ahead and see it's got formulas and
things like that in it
then well i mean yeah you're right i
mean it's hopeless
if you can't explain you know you're
right this is not explainable
at the um you know at the pre-out at the
pre-calculus level probably
it's probably by the time you've got
integrals for the orthogonality of the
functions
it's not explainable um so you know
but but let's see what um uh
but one thing go ahead you know
i think that there are many explanatory
models and people learn
differently some are visual learners
some are
verbal learners you know and some get
motivated by applications or
uses and i think that that just opens up
the space of what the computational
essay can capture
that different paths to learning uh
and motivation i think motivation is key
for instance
yeah but you see so right so so i think
that
one can criticize it but i think that
there's sort of different paths to
learning
yeah but this isn't a computational
essay this is just a math statement here
this this isn't you know the
computational essay version of this
would be
let's look at you know let's plot
i mean the computational essay kind of
discover it as you go
version would be i mean here you're just
you know you're announcing the
mathematics basically
so competitions you want are in the
subsequent
sections so this is more kind of lay out
what you're going to do and then show
how to do it
whereas what you're describing is a do
it as you're explaining it well let me
think you know
so here's a challenge can you explain
why sine x and sine 2x
are orthogonal well i bet you can i bet
if i say
filling arrow whatever axis here
i bet that i can see if i plot
sine 2x and i look at
the product of those two things right i
see those two
and i look at the product sine x
times sine 2x and then i bet
that you can see that by golly
the integral of that is zero see what
i'm saying
now you know maybe that's not i mean to
me
that would be a useful way to
to show people you know rather than them
having to work out the integral by hand
and say oh yeah it works out that way
you can just in fact i've never tried
this before this is kind of a cool thing
i didn't really know
you know look at this you can actually
see wowie look at that
if we mark these off in in two pies
let's take a look at this
isn't that cool i mean i'm sure you guys
all knew this i didn't know i mean i
didn't know you could
you know this is showing right the
integral of that is zero
and um everybody's either speechless or
doesn't agree with me
um is it
yeah it's hand waving
yeah i think what's your point your
point is
okay the question is okay so then we can
do something where we say
sine to x times sine no it's it's
beautiful stephen
but i say it's it's not a proof it's
plausible i know that but but this is
the point you're trying to get people to
understand so here
for example i never know which it is is
it trig reduces it trig expand
um okay
so
this here is looking better because when
we do this
we can see that you know the integral
over over 2 pi
is going to be zero there um
where am i putting this
um
so i mean you know again and that's a
more elementary thing than doing these
integrals probably
i don't know i don't even know how to do
that trig expansion anymore
um i only know how to do it in terms of
e to the ix and so on but
but um uh you know so i mean in terms of
these fourier series
you know what i would say is let's start
off from some
you know what what i would do if i was
doing this was i would say
you know i don't know what the fourier
series for what is the phrase series
kind of how do i work this out for a
series i'm going to do a square wave
uh fourier sine series uh how do i do
this
uh square wave of
x let's say x zero
to do i do it this way how do i do for a
site
roger somebody else yeah i mean yes but
but you probably want
square wave of pi x or some such because
that's gonna have period one
and the triggs are period two pi
and things like that okay all right okay
so
what's taking all this time what's it
doing
it's probably computing it
why is it hard isn't it just some
straightforward
some of um what is it like garbage
what is all that garbage
is this going to take it forever too
and i know this is a simple fairy series
is there a fourier n
uh no
well i don't know anyway okay so
let's just take this and let's take
um the first you know three terms of
that and so on
and so you don't want to scroll down the
computational essay where
i think you want you know square wave x
over two pi
because then then it matches nicely yes
[Music]
you want the lengths to be coincident
yeah
okay let's take a look eric has already
done this
there you go there's your triangle wave
or square wave or whatever
yeah well this isn't bad
i mean again i mean this is interesting
this looks pretty good
there we go finally finally the square
wave the cool that
i think that has the coolest plot at the
very bottom
with a good idea from michael which one
that one what the heck is it that's the
gibbs phenomenon
yeah nice oh that's nice
for continuous n yup
that's very nice wow never seen that
before
as usual michael has good ideas
that's why i wouldn't start with a
function that is discontinuous because
this
adds a whole bunch of complications into
the theory
third point i mean to me it's super
useful to say
here's where we're going we are trying
to okay here's what i would do
i would say this is a story of
approximating
you know functions by sums of sine sine
functions
okay why do we care a reason why
an example of a reason why we care is
because
you know the well the math version of it
is the sine functions the eigen
functions of
various operators but but we can say
that more
more you know that it's that if we
decompose things
into those then it's easy to tell what
happens because
it's easy to tell what happens to each
of those functions type thing
in other words you know that's the
plucked string version but
but in other words what what
okay what else would we say i mean like
like decomposing into sine functions
perhaps the other thing to say is and it
turns out to be very efficient to
decompose things into sine functions
which is why they're used in you know
jpegs or something like that
if it was incredibly slow to do that
decomposition they wouldn't be used
there
so that's another you know that is part
of the preamble
you know fact is that it could be
decomposing if i said to you
decompose this function into continued
fraction
of uh bessel functions or something
you'd be like i don't know how to do
that that's really hard but the fact
that fourier
series are useful is partly because it's
tolerably easy
to decompose things into fourier series
do you agree
roger michael anybody want to comment on
that yeah
yeah so so at the beginning here what i
would be saying is
rather than giving a very formal
definition
see i mean this is so off-putting to
somebody who is
you know yes if you're a math person
it's like like you know let f be a field
with these properties blah blah blah
blah blah
and you're off and running but that's
math people i mean
it's like
even does it cover sequences
because that's where it actually is easy
it's not so easy for functions it's very
easy the sequences
where you have the fast fourier transfer
less useful in terms of
of um uh
you mean fourier transforms yeah but
fourier transform and fourier series are
not cheap to compute
to discrete fourier transforms are cheap
yes commenting on a live stream
but he's saying he usually starts by
saying how do we represent tides or
heartbeats or other periodic phenomena
yeah that's a that's a good that's a i
mean so that's a
appealing to applications which i think
is motivating i think motivation i mean
of course
which is what any of those applications
is okay
both tides and heartbeats well
you know the tides for example well
they're not as periodic as you think
they might be you know they have an
18-year period roughly
right or something but um it's a bit
i mean uh that's a slightly
see see this is one of the things i
always find curious about explaining
stuff
is like i'm reminded of a silly
silly story okay i was looking years ago
for about some history project i was
looking at um
uh for video footage of john von neumann
okay and there is at least at the time
there was only one known
piece of uh video footage of him which
is him being on a television show
with a very 1950s title of something
like youth wants to know
okay and it's like um
uh and you know he's being introduced to
some you know member of the atomic
energy commission and so on he's got
some some device
there and um uh
some kid is asking about this device and
it's like the device has all kinds of
pieces and so on
and turns out the thing the kid really
points to is the carrying case for the
device
right and so john von neumann rather
charmingly explains oh that's just the
carrying case
but the whole point is when you try and
show people things
what's the carrying case and what's the
actual thing
see what i'm saying like if i said this
this is the tides let's say well the
periodicity of the tides is complicated
i mean if if we go and look i'm sure we
can um
uh um you know if we go and and
pull up uh your average um
let's see if we go just go to wolf alpha
and we say you know something like um
you know tides
in new york harbor
and we say more days and it's like
you know hello periodic function
it's sort of periodic well actually it
looks more periodic than i remembered it
um but i mean i don't know that it's
always that i don't think it is always
that periodic i think there are plenty
of places where it looks a lot less
periodic than that
but so again this is my question if
you're showing something like this if it
if it's
it's just tough because it's like what
when you when you start explaining that
it gets a little kind of you know what
are you supposed to notice what are you
not supposed to notice
did this make any sense to anybody i
mean i think that the the um
uh um you're trying to teach the way you
learn
which is developing an intuition and i
think the way
some of these computational essays have
been presented
is a start from a very low entry point
give all the basics like a textbook
and then add examples so that people can
start you're starting with the
intuition side um
craig here is saying that he has tied
data from 2019 in boston
and asks students to find the dominant
frequencies you see it's not fair
because i
i know using meta information that craig
is teaching mit
undergraduates which is which is
definitely already a very um
uh a very kind of selected set um
and and for them that sounds like
exactly the right level of
of thing to do um the uh
um i mean i think that um
um the uh
one thing that that computational essays
have an easy time doing
is to explore examples and do intuition
builders
yes and
one thing that's hard when you have to
manually do it
is to to do it enough intuition builders
so so one is in some sense data rich for
example
rich in a computational setting
right by the way aaron on our live
stream is commenting on
on the fact that he wants a um an analog
of our function documentation where you
can just sort of
open up something about fourier series
and see a bunch of examples and just
understand how to do them i i absolutely
agree that's what we
i mean you know and that's what we kind
of all keep on saying is that
that i mean if we go let's even go to
the fourier sign
uh um so i want to
preamble that by saying that this is in
the old style of book appendix
documentation
for some migrating these i mean okay
give us an example that isn't roger
limit okay but i mean even here okay
even here we are
even here this is pretty good it's like
i'm not totally clueless okay t is a
little confusing that it's t
comma t okay whatever i wouldn't you
know again that's that's like a little
confusing but here
i've already got a lot of the points you
know i'm i'm writing it as some sum of
signs
and it reproduces the result but not
exactly
that's that's a good start um
and uh but i just want to say with the
sentiment
it is our goal and we are migrating
pages from
uh sort of computer manual pages to
learning pages
and how do i see that here roger sorry
how what i mean you mean i mean the
examples then
you know that they should then be sort
of oh for god's sake
this is horrifying this is just
horrifying
i mean that at the very least should be
didn't exist at the time there are six
thousand pages to go through
and i can eyes fair enough
but you know the reason that i'm
objecting and in terms of us talking
about exposition
it's like that's you know somebody was
commenting on you know what's math
what's computeristic
and so on that's a piece of pure
computeristic random crud
right i mean that's not i mean i would
also have argued
that if you're really going to do it
that way you would be better off to say
something like
you know show this
with you know graphics point
one and you know the fact that we've got
an actual point
size graphics thank you
yeah well obviously that didn't work um
there
i know it's there but it didn't work in
a nice way
um i'm
i see he's asking is epilogue not
recommended no it's not there's anything
wrong with epilogue
i'm just saying that conceptually if i'm
thinking about
i'm doing limits i'm plotting functions
oh my god
we just dive deep into the entrails of
the of the
animal so to speak seeing all of these
very computeristic
you know epilogue sequencing of graphics
type stuff
um the
um i think uh
um but look in in terms of of
let's take the fourier series example i
think we're all saying
i mean even what to me um
you know maybe i'm wrong but i think
this is um
you know seeing this i'm not so keen on
the t
comma t that's a bit confusing i mean if
i said t
squared here would i be toast um that's
a bit messy
but um and that's a little bit
incomprehensible
okay um and obviously what we've got to
explain is this is representing things
periodically blah blah blah
it might be better to not plot it over
this larger range i don't know
um but but um i mean again again this is
this is the carrying case phenomenon
right when you say t comma t comma five
it's like what's what here what am i
supposed to be paying attention to
is it important that those two things
are the same is it
you get what i'm saying maybe maybe i'm
being
unclear here but i mean you know it's
like like there's a there's a payload
and there's a like a uh you know there's
the t that's representing the the
independent variable
and help me to distinguish those just by
looking at this example
okay yeah like it tutti coma t
yeah even just just just would help yes
that would help
and i mean here if we were explaining
this for the first time
we might not want to do this we might
want to say you know
zero to two pi i don't know what this is
going to do if i do zero to two pi
oh disaster well whatever i mean in in
um
um and this is a case where you have to
sort of understand a bit more
than your you know it might take for me
to find this example
i might spend a few minutes puttering
around
trying to find the example that is going
to look reasonable here
and that's um you know that is both
going to have the constraint of being
simple
being sort of payload distinguished from
dependent variable
being whatever to to actually work but i
mean to me
and um uh look the first
point is that i might almost argue
is i mean you know what we're really
talking about is here
is how do you build up a function from
sines and cosines
okay that i think that's the main point
and
one point that i think craig is
implicitly making is it's really all
about periodic functions
and i suppose i'm eliding that point a
bit and maybe maybe one shouldn't maybe
one should
just take that head on that this is
about about periodic functions
and say uh you know
i'm not sure maybe maybe yes
yeah maybe it's right to think i mean
again that's another
one of these expositional things is
yeah i think it's probably right i think
you have to you have to say it's about
periodic functions otherwise otherwise
it doesn't make a lot of sense and
you're going to get
weird confusing things like this which
is probably why we shouldn't use a
function that isn't periodic here
am i making sense i don't know what the
right um
uh which means we're probably using
triangle waves and things of that kind
um but uh
well but then okay
look in terms of the presentation of
this i mean to me
as i think roger is saying other people
are saying the big
new freedom that we have is we can
quickly show an example if you're
writing a textbook there's no choice but
to do this
right so if we scroll down here why the
heck are we talking about shifted
fourier series
in section two here we don't even know
we haven't even seen a single picture
of anything we're already talking about
shifted fourier series
eric explain yourself here
um
because in most cases uh as the example
is mentioned earlier like tights or
heartbeat
heartbeat is not pi seconds the height
is not pi days
it's some other unit so we need one that
doesn't go from pi to pi we need one
from
generic l to minus l all right this is
another exposition principle right
the the um i mean
you know what is obvious to people and
what isn't
and you know we've learned that over the
years in language design
lots of things where people immediately
extrapolate
and they don't get confused and things
where people get irreducibly confused
and you know i would argue i don't know
you know do you need this piece of
scaffolding to not get confused
i don't know i mean or is it the case
that
you just elide it you cheat you make the
first example be
something where it so happens that
everything lines up with
you know pi two pi periodicity
and then only later do you go back and
say oh actually
you know we can deal with any
periodicity so to speak so i can't speak
for other people but i can speak for
myself
as a physics student many years ago this
was exactly the point that tripped me up
about furrier series
and i wish that somebody had sort of
done this right at the very get-go so
this is actually reflecting my own
educational bias in that if i would have
understood this point i would have got
it right away instead of it taking me a
while
to figure out what was going on well
okay so this is always the challenge so
you know one of my expositional things i
i've you know i
you know i always criticize british
textbooks of various kinds
you know there was a different style and
maybe not um
uh not in the um um
various people saying yes i don't know
what they're saying yes too so that was
perhaps the commenting on on eric's
eric's comments here but
but um uh the um you know i was going to
say british versus american textbooks
back in the day probably they've
normalized by now the british textbooks
were always full of trickery
like i remember there was an
electromagnetism book where every
example it gave was a trick
that is you could do it in this
particular case because
these functions decomposed in this way
blah blah blah blah
whereas the corresponding american
textbook in those days
was let's deal with this bigger
industrial machine
that is harder to understand but will
bash through all these different
examples
and i have to say you know i'm
advocating
you know what i'm advocating is the
trickery that isn't really trickery
trickery that is readily generalizable
so to speak
um and uh
um but okay so people are agreeing that
shifted fourier series is an important
concept
um uh they which doesn't mean that
the normal furry series out of the box
shouldn't be given a few examples in
some
uh some amount of space up top
but the expense of course is the essay
gets longer
well okay and the other problem is
there's a point at which the the
the you know the student has already
drowned
you know they gave up they're like i'm
not going to understand this
i drowned um and you know i think you
have to get to something that they can
understand
within a fairly short distance or you're
going to have that phenomenon
um i mean i think
you see yeah i mean and this again
it's also a difference you know i know
from dealing with
groups of like kids and people you know
high school kids and other things like
that
you know if you're in some group of kids
and you're explaining something about
language and you're giving examples and
so on and some kid asks some question
about
uh you know just just tell me what the
formal definition
is you know structure structure
structure and formal definition
you can pretty much say and i have gone
back and checked a few times
i can say you are going to be a pure
mathematician or something like that
because those are the only people who
think that way and um
sure enough that that's usually what
happens um
and you know so there are certain people
who who who think in terms of the formal
definition and then work back down from
that
most do not at least that's my
my anecdotal observation i mean most
people find it easier
some some people say you know given the
structure you know
n is an element of blah blah blah blah
blah is a you know
like my favorite example is a touring
machine as a quintuple
which has always struck me as being you
know just horrendously structured
and it's like you know you could say
okay well fair enough it is a quintuple
in some sense but
i wouldn't have said it that way i've
said a turing machine has this
tape and it has these things on it has
this head you're kind of building up
this idea of what a turing machine is
rather than just boom you know a touring
machine as a quintuple
but people you know who like pure
mathematics like
this kind of a touring machine as a
quintuple i think um
and again here if i'm to criticize this
it's it's some you know this is a very
structured
statement this is what it is and as a
refresher
that's clearly a good thing as a like
why would i write this down
like why would i write this you know if
i'm if i'm just coming to this from
nothing
it's like okay that's nice why do i
write that why don't i write
sine of sine of x why is that not here
you know well that happens to be fm
synthesis but you know
what um and you know when i look at the
series it's like
okay then i start getting even more
confused it's like well guess what i
mean i wonder whether that series
converges you know
but that was what cantor asked that led
to transfinite numbers and everything
else
um but what is my point
i mean i guess i guess
i'm you know again everybody has a
different style
but you know to me it's useful to see
this very practical
this is an example of a fourier series
and this is roughly what it does
because now i kind of know that what i'm
trying to do is approximate some
function
so stephen the part of the bad news here
is that
your reaction to this particular
computational exposition essay whatever
is similar to uh
the ones that other people have written
so i think you're in the situation where
you have not yet found a single case
where you are happy uh with the way
this has been done well you're probably
right and i mean you know there was one
that i wrote as a sample
which i'm probably also not happy with
so let me critique my own example
um you know very useful information but
that then the natural
follow-up from that is how do we come up
with one that you are having
let's find does somebody know where the
um uh
okay so i had this one from 2017. so
i i have a potential suggestion so it
seems like steven is not opposed to
the content that you have eric but uh
that
it starts relatively technical and then
comes to the examples
and for the free series this is what the
fourier series is there's nothing to be
say there's no discussion there's no
other possibility
but what about if one would slightly
invert it
and say what kind of function can i
build
just from sign and course make a
manipulate with literally 100 sliders
or points that you can move around and
always show that you can make a
good approximation and then turn it
around
yeah that's kind of the computational
what what
where you're exploring computationally
in order to motivate something that
might actually be true
basically you can approximate any
function as it seems so let's really do
this
that's interesting i mean okay let's
critique one that i wrote a while ago
four years ago or something now so
can you make it a little bit bigger yep
okay and i think i wrote this very
quickly and i think it's probably bad
for many different reasons but let's
just look at it and we can all tear it
apart
okay so first point is it's an important
result in statistics
okay
okay i mean i don't know whether we we
you know you can argue about is that um
um uh
you know it seems useful to me to say
that so what is the analogous statement
for fourier series
see this is way more technical
fourier series are a way of writing
you know periodic
functions or something as sums of sines
and cosines
by the way when you say sine and cosine
terms you're not even telling me
you know i'm thinking about sine square
root of 2x
but you don't mean that what is a term i
don't know what a term is
well it's not so i i need the equation
to say what term is and without spending
a whole
paragraph without the equation it's hard
to do
so i see what you're saying but no i get
it but i think i think what you want to
say is something like
writing a function an arbitrary function
as a sum of sine functions
fourier series are a way of writing any
function
any periodic function as a sum
of sine functions sine and cosine
functions whatever
um you know that that will be a good
preamble statement
so you know roughly where you're going
then this is useful because or something
or this is um uh and the fact the
mechanics of how it works
that that there's orthogonality between
different functions
that to me is plumbing about how it
works not what it is
because you know the fact that oh well
we're going to do it in terms of
chebyshev functions oh they have a
different weighting blah blah blah blah
blah
would be like you know then the question
is
how do i write this in terms of a sum of
chebyshev functions
the fact that my mechanics for you know
generating that series
uses a different you know way of of
of extracting the terms is a different
story i mean
let's tear apart my my effort over here
okay so i mean my effort here
is sort of the experimental
um
okay
okay
i mean again please criticism because
this is the so far looks okay to me i
mean i would change this to code text
but that's a
that's a micro detail of modern of the
modern thing that we didn't have in
2017.
um
well you assume someone knows what a
normal distribution is is that safe to
assume
no depends on the audiences no it's not
it's not um that's a good point this
probably should say a normal paren
gaussian bell curve a normal
you know so this would probably be a
better version bell curve i would have
heard of
yeah so so if you say that that would
probably be a better way to do it
i'll just say this in a different place
so i don't confuse this
um i agree that would that's a good
change because that way
that that gives a sort of uh um by
putting it in parens and quotes
you're kind of um right
um
i mean yeah it's a good change
um
okay but but i mean again let's tear
this apart i'm i'm um
uh for example for a student does it
matter why you started with 1 000
what if we start with lower number does
it make any difference
they can try it we're about to try a
thousand we're going to try a hundred
thousand again
the reason i didn't start with a lower
number is because it's again it's like
the carrying case problem
right if i start if that number is
instead 100
right what the heck am i supposed to
learn from that picture
i don't know okay why two of them what's
the diff why do you need both
does the result change isn't the central
limit theorem
true in both cases you can just say
better with the reason i'm saying
i'm using a thousand a hundred thousand
because i'm showing that it gets flatter
by the time you get to a hundred
thousand here
one thing that i would confuse me is uh
what is the relation of the number of
bins
if you make a hundred thousand bin it
doesn't look flat at all
okay you're you're in a carrying case
i'm i'm referring to this as the
carrying case problem right
what is it that you're supposed to
notice here
and i noticed that kind of by clever
pinsides
selection it looks flat
you're right you're right now would
people actually notice that or not i
don't know
i mean again the problem is it's like
here's here's the thing you get when
people write
documentation okay people say you didn't
say the important thing
in the documentation you should have
said first
like your fourier series thing this
point about about
uh you know shifted fourier series you
should have said that first
okay so you go around you talk to other
people and
eventually they uh you know everybody
says you should have said this thing
first and pretty soon you've got 50
things you should say first
and guess what that doesn't work there's
only one thing you say first
so it's this challenge of what can you
allied while not having people get
confused
and you know yes i think you've got to
pick your poison
um the uh you see if you do the same
number of bins it isn't going to work
and the whole point is we're not trying
to give a
sense we're trying to give the sense
which i'm cheating on here
okay let's be realistic i'm cheating
about the fact that it looks flatter
when there are a hundred thousand bins
um and you know the question is is that
cheat okay
or is that my complaint about the
electromagnetism book
where every every thing that's done is a
cheat
no i think actually if you keep the
number of bins it becomes more visible
to your point
it's more emphasized well fair enough
okay but
then the cost of that is that i have to
like let's say here
i say 0.1 or something and then i would
say
here um uh
0.1
but then okay that's kind of nice um but
then i've got to
but see i'm not even sure this is my
point that that it gets flatter
okay so so this is what your expertise
is out so
i know i know i know i know i know but
whether that's necessary
so craig made the point i would show a a
a
a um a gaussian earlier i mean
maybe
you know you're right it it might be
hmm
i don't disagree that that's a but but
on the other hand
there is a certain value to the drama of
something showing you know
appearing i mean that has and the
problem is if one's going to give it
i mean one could say at the very
beginning um
you know a bell curve distribution
i mean if i was if this wasn't in the
form of an abstract i would say
kind of like this where at least you
you know you show um
you know whatever where i'm saying and
this is another question about how we do
this
because i'm not sure what the right
thing to do is um
okay now i say like this you know i fold
that up
um and you know i have to say
in the time since i wrote this
particular piece i have done more and
more
of my writing of kind of expositional
stuff for the physics project and so on
where what i found pretty useful is you
just give a result like this
and you want to know what the code is
just open it up or use texture copy
um and uh
so i mean that's a question is to what
extent can these essays
be things where you show a result here
where you have to open the code
explicitly and to what extent is it kind
of visible code
um uh somebody's asking what was
actually in john 1 9
case in the anecdote it's a geiger
counter it was a good counter
um radiation detector
uh
the um in any case
yeah i don't disagree that this is
rather it's rather long in the tooth
here
it's an awful lot is
the the the ten seems very
metrically decimal tender to me here
well this is another one of these
arguments about oh i see what you're
saying
but but look if i'd chosen michael what
number would you have chosen there
11. see i don't like that
because by saying a level i just wanted
this for the base
always wanted 11 as the base of the
decimal system
what a nut case did he also want to
uh was he also arguing for the the
uh well uh
a prime number of hours in the day or
something
um why did he want that michael he
wanted something in the order of 10
which he agreed was useful but it was
the nearest that wasn't divisible in
year 10.
why did he want something not divisible
because because he wanted to go away
from this old babylonian
two times three times five he wanted
something
holistic one piece
great why
i mean isn't it useful to be able to
subdivide the units
i don't know anyway that's interesting i
didn't know that piece of history but
but the reason i wouldn't do that
okay is i i you know the question is
what's the significance of that 10 right
and you might say i mean if i said this
finds the mean of 13 random numbers
to me that raises more questions than it
answers
it's like 10 okay you're just sort of
showing a bunch of numbers
whereas 13 it's like why is it 13 is
there something special about it being a
prime
is there you know whatever i mean that
would be my objection to that i don't
know what do you
i mean we're all you know we're
experienced
expositors of things so i'm curious
about your
thinking here because i would never
consider putting 11 there
michael the 10 just i have nothing
against the 10
but you used 100 10 000
and now now there's a 10 in a spot
that's unrelated to this
round numbers that you used earlier but
it gives me the feeling there's a
relation
no it's an absolutely fair criticism
right
so how does one deal with that um
oh by the way the reason that i'm making
this list of ten random numbers
is to show people before we go into
histograms roughly what on earth are we
actually talking about here
um
yeah i mean look honestly if we could
get away with five i would use five here
because that's another kind of
reasonable number that isn't isn't a ten
ten-ish number
i would just consider using 20 but i
wouldn't consider using a non-round
number
would 20 make you happier yeah 80 yes
i you're probably right i mean that's a
good that's a good
um and 20 is just fine here
um oh god yeah okay your
your criticism is very valid on this
line
right that's confusing i agree with you
and um okay fine and then maybe here
see okay that's fine so that's okay
um
uh i mean i i claim that comments like
that are useful
right in other words to make people to
highlight for people
look it's not flat as opposed to the
distribution of the numbers themselves
which is flat
the distribution of the of the means of
collections of numbers
is not flat um
and here we're kind of running into
various issues about
about um um
oh okay see here oh gosh
see here what i'm doing is i'm trying to
explain
up here the thing that i was pushing
back on here
is i don't want to have to explain what
that brace point one is
and again that's one of these that's
sort of the inverse carrying case
problem
have you added a bunch of stuff here
what is that extra stuff
you know oh my gosh i can understand
histogram of random reel a thousand
because i just saw a random reel 10 here
but what's that my
you know what's that brace point one
that's something weird that's like the
epilogue thing
that we saw earlier
um
well anyway i mean i think look
it's some
i mean i don't know you know maybe this
is just me but to me i find this kind of
sort of i would get much more motivated
after your first experiment and before
the normal distribution
i would now like to see say a
transformed distribution with
2 3 4 5 6 up to 20
and see how it really approaches the
gaussian because right now i have no
idea if that would be a good thing
or if this is a reality
yes i agree what i did here which is
sort of okay
is i don't know what this um
uh
well i'm i'm looking at other
distributions for the individual
objects and i that's probably not the
best way to get it but that was a way to
get and i think that's useful but
i agree with you before that one should
have the sequence once you just have the
table
of of results i agree that that
that makes good sense and see the limit
happen
and then the next big result is it
doesn't matter what the underlying
distribution is and i would actually
break that off as a separate section
because although the central limit
theorem is all about the fact that it
doesn't matter what the underlying
distribution is
in a sense the first step is just
uh sort of you know finding finding the
gauss you know finding the normal
distribution or something
and then the next thing is uh it doesn't
matter what the underlying
structure you know what the underlying
distribution is you'll always get the
normal distribution
um steven to to what extent we should
care about labeling you know this
visualization
like as they or is it good or like you
know we should add more
content there to help them well i mean i
think this is it helps to have this be
explicitly a you know code text
thing so at least you have some
anchor for what's going on here if you
just look at this picture you say that's
a cool picture
what is it i mean that's unfortunately a
little bit
you know down in the weeds but um i mean
i tend to think i don't think it should
have a
i do not think it should have a plot
label
i think one of the motivations you know
so some people get motivated of what you
can do
with something one you can be motivated
by sort of exploring and discovering a
result
but the fact that the conversion normal
means that
one can assume normality for a lot of
things that means so much simpler
i know so so that's that would be a good
thing to have at the end here
right now and the other thing at the end
is like
it doesn't converge to normal in general
i know i know i know
but okay so these are pretty nice
pictures
okay so i i i did exactly that
where the normal distribution appears
except i didn't finish it and i was
going to talk about error distribution
some blood levels but not all okay
here's a good example of where
that you know that's the distribution of
lengths of words which is not a normal
distribution
not everything is um
and you know find some data show some
that are show some that aren't
um i agree
i think it might also but some then the
sums can converge to a stable
distribution
you know they can converge the
distribution that's not normal
but what i would be more concerned here
is that
not immediately the simple thing goes to
a normal distribution but generically it
goes to f of normal distribution
because you know like string length it
sounds natural but it really isn't
it might be a lot of strings
does somebody who goes to a normal
distribution
frequently
um
you see we've got they take five sites
making comments so you see
this is the the there are too many
experts here
about how to about exposition for these
things um
the uh um
uh let's see it's more visually
intuitive you start with something with
non-zero mean
that's interesting that's a good point
i mean and again okay so
you know when you do one of these
expositions
there are you know there will be and you
know michael and i keep on and others
here keep on coming up with
just think about plotting this thing
just think about plotting that thing
often i've had you know this is my
what are they called in sports you know
the money shot or something or whatever
it is i don't know what the
the um uh you know maybe that's
photography i don't know but but you
know
the the the the the really cool
particular visualization that kind of
is is the is the is the top
visualization so to speak and
you know to my mind you know i
sort of pride myself on usually being
able to figure out what that is
and that's a useful thing to think about
is is there some visualization that you
are aiming towards
that you need to kind of build up to and
then you know some visualization where
once somebody sees it they're like oh i
get it
um and uh i'm not sure what point i was
really making there but but um
um um
i mean it's kind of fun to see that
these they're these cases where
as you make the sums over more and more
numbers
you get something you know it goes
through these weird shapes and then ends
up as a gaussian
and i admit that yeah well let's see
what else are we going to achieve here
i'm i'm really
late for something else i've been been
um um
actually this is a pretty decent picture
um what is our objective here our
objective is
okay so first point is i think it is
super challenging to write expositions
where you don't
understand fairly far ahead of the
actual exposition you're trying to write
it's worse to write it in such cases
yeah it'll be a muddle and it will not
do our product or our people
credit right i mean
honestly i've i've gotten better over
the years of being able to get the
distance between
you know the the the limit of my
understanding and what i'm explaining to
be
slightly shorter but it takes it takes
you know
i think it takes i don't know how
perfectly i do it but it takes a lot of
self-awareness of what
where when you are stepping on something
that you really don't understand
um and how you avoid that um but uh uh
you know which is to say
okay so another question is and this is
something you know
when do people who are now you know it's
a paradox right because
on the one hand you say you have to
understand it very well on the other
hand by the time you understand it very
well
you're in the weeds you know you know
it's like i've worked with people in
rogers team many times
where it's like there's an example and
they're like oh of course it's this
example and it's uh
you know it's got unbelievable amounts
of hair in it so to speak
and and to them they don't even notice
it because they're so
steeped in that particular area and it
takes real effort to say what's the
point what can we get rid of here
what actually matters what doesn't um so
i mean on the one hand it's important to
know the material
on the other hand you have to kind of
back away from that and say what's the
minimal thing that i can get away with
talking about
so in a sense expert writes writes it
non-experts
reviews it that's a good thing to do
if you can have a you see the problem
with non-experts okay
the problem is this that people
they have to be obnoxious non-experts
like me
who who have sufficient self-confidence
that i don't really
you know to say i don't understand that
is not something that bothers me so to
speak i'm well aware that there are
a great many things that i don't
understand and the trouble is
that a lot of people if you say review
this if they don't i mean this is this
is a classic problem that we we don't
have around our company
as much as many people have it you know
that which you don't understand you
always assume to be true
i mean arguably it's a problem in the
world in general you know
people people have a habit of if they
don't understand something
and somebody is telling them i'm the
expert and this is how it works
and they don't understand it it's like
they say oh it must be true
um and i i know you know my
my late friend dick feynman was very big
on the
there are no experts just although his
version of that was a little different
than my version of it which would be
you know i'm arrogant enough to believe
that if i can't understand it then
i don't believe it so to speak but that
doesn't mean that i
you know but yet what am i trying to say
i think it is non-trivial to have
non-experts review it
unless they are in a mindset where
they fully believe that they should be
able you know that
you know where they never take the point
of view that if they don't understand it
it's their problem type thing
and they're making sense i mean so in
other words you can take the point of
view
i don't understand that and it's my
problem because i'm just
too clueless to understand it or you can
take to the point of view
if i don't understand it i'm gonna push
i'm gonna push i'm gonna push i'm
to ask explain explain explain explain
explain and if i
really just don't understand it it's you
know
it's a problem with the thing that's
being explained not it's a problem with
me
um and you know i don't know it's hard
to find non-expert reviewers who have
that point of view
but but i think as as it was said here
many times it's important to start these
essays by
what it is and why we care and i think
that part
should obviously anyone understand and
then
at that point they would just know
whether they want to carry on with how
to do it
and how to do it can be done in
different ways that that is very
subjective to the way that the author is
used to writing or has learned the topic
himself
and so forth and and probably by the
time you're committed to learn
um however it's written the how we do it
part
it you'll probably try your best to get
it
get it through charlie i think it's
important the thing to understand is
you know the style of writing that you
know eric
did in math world that wikipedia has
done so on
this direct just tell it go say what's
true
and don't i mean like for example a
bunch of writing that i do
it's like sometimes it gets really
complicated so for example here's an
issue
if it gets complicated what do you do
and one thing i tend to do is i trend to
say
it's a subtle point that blah blah blah
blah blah
in other words you're signaling this is
getting complicated
and rather than just you just dive right
into it
and somebody says oh my god i didn't
understand that this is getting way too
complicated at least if you signal
this is getting complicated then you
know
then there's a a chance that people can
put up their
wait a minute i have to go bit slower
i'm not going to understand this as
quickly
and and get it rather than just they
barrel right through it and they say oh
my gosh you didn't understand that
um i mean i think that uh uh you know i
i do think you know look the question of
who we're writing these things for
the the interesting thing about
mathworld slash wikipedia
has been that although like in the math
area like wikipedia has gotten too
complicated in many cases
because i think it's gotten too much
infected by
essentially pure mathematicians writing
for peer mathematicians
um whereas you know i think
if we can write it i mean i i would like
to claim
that there's there's lots of writing
that has the property that anybody can
understand it
although not everybody will care about
it
i mean i don't know what tim uh
but i mean charlie your point of say up
front why one cares look look i'll
tell you when i write things and
obviously i write lots of stuff
like you know i was writing okay let's
bring up we can criticize something of
mine again for just a second here
um let's just pull something up here um
and uh um
okay like this was a thing i just wrote
um
how inevitable is the concept of numbers
okay so if we look at some section here
uh
you know every section there is at least
an attempt
to frame the thing in in
like what's the uh what's the point i
don't know whether that's a good one but
let's
try again for one of these um
okay i mean again you know i try to give
these kind of introductory
blurbs that are like saying what's the
point of that section so to speak
um
uh
yeah i mean again each one of these
these probably took some effort i don't
the product didn't take very many
minutes but
but you know to what's the point of this
section
why do we use numbers so much is it
something about the world or is it
something more something about us
okay at least you know what the question
is there i would claim
yeah i agree and uh
you know again here whatever their role
in science technology society one place
where numbers seem fundamentally central
is mathematics again yeah i mean
this is a this is a good argument for
now i know what the point is of this
section
i may or may not care about it but i
know what the point is
um and uh you know i i will tell you
when i write these things
i usually you know sometimes i i nail
these intro paragraphs very quickly
sometimes i noodle for five minutes or
ten minutes or something
and i have many versions of them where
there they're considerably more
complicated and eventually they get
simpler
and eventually they're fairly direct um
i don't know what uh
what else is there another one here um
um
yeah okay so again
it's like how do you start this section
right and um you kind of have to say
something but somewhat hard hitting
and somewhat you know positioning for
what the heck you're going to do
um anyway i mean i think i agree that
the
it's you know what you say first is
important and we've tried to do that in
the introductions to guide pages and
things like this
i mean obviously here this is in terms
of writing
this is what i think they teach the kids
is called a hook
it's like like what do you do what do
you write to get people to go on reading
so to speak
um the uh um
and usually in times when i've i have to
say
usually in terms of making those hooks
when i've ever explained stuff to people
and when
when i explain something to people and
people just look sort of blank
and like i don't care eventually i might
find a hook
where they say oh okay that seems
interesting that's probably a good sign
that that should be the very beginning
of the
of the essay type type thing i mean
obviously this is not
an expositional essay this is a
different kind of essay
um but uh uh
anyway okay next steps here and we
should uh enhance this commenting that
should have a link to the word random
yeah i mean you see this is again
this is where things get complicated
it's like yes
i could write and have written hundreds
of pages
on what the meaning of the word random
is um
but you can't say everything first and
you have to assume
people i mean this is i mean okay at a
very meta philosophical level
you know the very fact that we're
writing in english so to speak
we are assuming we are leveraging you
know we built a tower of understanding
represented by the words in english and
we are leveraging that understanding
by the things that were you know if we
didn't have the english words
we wouldn't have anything we're
leveraging that understanding we have to
assume people have sort of a rough
intuitive sense of what random means
even if they don't understand you know
chaitan komagro of algorithmic
complexity you know
this that or the other or von mises
theory of randomness or all these kinds
of things
you know we've got to assume just like
we use an english word we've got to
assume that people get something out of
that
now by the way extending that discussion
when we
write pieces of computational language
the question is
what level i mean this is another good
question of audience
what level of understanding so so i
would like to make the claim
that well if i get rid of that point one
which i don't like very much
um the i don't like it just because it's
a it's an extra piece of hair in this in
this input
i would like to make the claim that
there's a decent chance okay so
so one thing with this is it which is
going to help i think a lot
is the new formatting which have you
guys seen this maybe
i don't know if anybody can pull it up
jeremy's new formatting of code
have you seen that stuff let me just um
bring that up if i can uh
anybody know what i'm talking about yeah
not me well i i certainly do but that
do you know what yeah okay right because
i'm part of those conversations
do you happen to know here we go
um okay this is a this is not a very
good example but
but um the idea is
to make code one of the goals is
to make you know math is pleasant to
read in a document
i mean it kind of looks stylish code has
a habit of not looking so stylish
the question is how do we avoid that and
so we've been experimenting with these
things like
graying down the kind of the the
infrastructure operators and things like
that
um and uh you know i think we can solve
the problem
of making it kind of easy to read this
like i read this like i read words
histogram random real
um and you know if i gray down these
operators a bit
then what i'm seeing is something that
is as unforbidding
as uh you know as a piece of english
text so to speak and that to me is an
important goal
um the uh
um
yeah right so so let's see um
okay craig is commenting the fact that
paragraphs are short makes it less
daunting
which is probably a good rule for essays
i agree with you the code should be
thought short the paragraph should be
short
um and i know i have to go here uh and
aaron is commenting
that it'd be interesting to take a paper
from archive and see how to make it more
readable
you know yes there is unbelievably low
hanging fruit
i mean you know sometimes they're good
but sometimes it's like oh my
gosh why did you explain that third when
you should have explained that first
why did you get to the point only at the
end of the i mean in a sense
what you learn you know as you try and
look at technical papers in different
fields and it's different in different
fields
you learn the kind of the formula for
where do you actually go to find out
what they're talking about
because it's often not the main flow of
the paper
you know you'll go to you know i often
read the conclusion section first
in many kinds of kinds of papers um
because that's where they finally
loosened up to the point where they're
not
so you know tangled up in their own
definitions
that they can't say anything and where
you get some sort of
intuitive description of we figured out
this and this and this and then go back
and say
now i don't really believe you i want to
know the details but it will be
enough and you know it's what abstracts
are supposed to do but i think
sometimes abstracts are good i mean i've
noticed because i've been writing
abstracts for things of mine recently
i have a terrible habit of making them
sound formulaic and academic
which makes them less you know they're
not as flowing
as the things will might write you know
just sort of here's what the point is so
to speak
um anyway yeah i mean look this is a
i mean uh years ago uh andre probably
remembers this at least we used to have
for technical writers at the company we
used to have
a list of some principles of technical
writing which the zeroth
one was you've got to understand what
you're writing about
um i wonder whether that list whether
that description is still around
somewhere
but yeah i mean so
look the this question structurally
how do we do this you know i think
it is necessary the people who are
writing these are real experts
it is also very useful if there is a
reviewer who can play the fool
so to speak and is prepared to do that
and it's not going to have the point of
view if they don't understand it then
it's that they're clueless type thing
um yeah i mean so
so shoddy i think in in your efforts you
know
we have to develop that that kind of
pattern of who writes who comments on it
who complains about the fact that they
can't understand it i mean roger i'm
sure you're doing this a whole bunch
with primary documentation
of cleaning it up like that is that a
true statement yeah
absolutely a lot you see you and i
both end up being pretty good at playing
the fool so to speak
i suspect i mean in other words but the
other thing that i have learned is that
what people learn i mean at least to a
certain level
let's say that there's a book style okay
we know several series of books that
have a style a very direct style just
like eric established a style for math
world and
and so on and we have a style that we do
our documentation
absolutely it helps people a lot to have
that very structured thing right there's
a lot of things to look at
there's a lot of problems solved and
occasionally
uh not so right but then we have to go
back and
sort of get it well right and and the
question then is
if there is a structure somebody says
but i need to make an exception
right and you know
usually the best answer is no
because you know usually it's like well
just rethink how you're doing it so it
fits
sorry you know everything has to be less
than a line long reword it
break it into two pieces you know rather
than
oh well we can make an exception here
because the exception is a slippery
slope that leads to something completely
different in the end
exactly but people need a bunch of
sort of practical tricks and the way you
pick up a lot of practical tricks is by
reading or seeing other
you know something oh i agree it's it's
like the the famous
encyclopedist trick you know where
they write it is said that blah blah
blah blah blah
which basically means this is a
controversial fact
which you know some people say and some
people say it isn't true
or we really have no good evidence for
this but it is said that
you know it's a convenient kind of way
to present something
um in fact i notice i i'm sure i did
that in this essay
it said that there are human languages
now you know behind that statement was
me doing a bunch of research
about whether that was really true or
not and it's complicated
and so the best i could do with it said
that
um because i didn't want to get into the
whole you know
oh well there are these numeric
languages and
there are these you know western
influences on a numeric languages blah
blah blah blah blah
you know that's just sinking into the
mud
um but yes i agree roger that that is a
good thing to have a family of those
kinds of tricks
um i think we need to do another one of
these discussions i think this is useful
i think maybe what we should do next
time
is to actually enumerate some of these
principles
like you know when we are structuring
and you know we don't really have a
great structure you know this was my
attempt to make a structure for a
computational essay and
you know and then people kept on not
following it so to speak
um and it's either is a structure that's
going to work or it isn't a structure
that's going to work
and that you know is something that um
uh
we should determine i mean like here
this doesn't follow that structure it
doesn't have an intro
thing you know so it loses
at that level and um uh
and again it doesn't have no you know
look
there was a structure there was a style
here the style is which is the eiwl
style
there's a paragraph that explains things
then there's a
caption to a piece of of computational
language
and i think that's a pretty good scheme
we don't have these explainer paragraphs
in documentation right now and
and i think a little teaser of the
result on the top as well
because some of these may get very long
that's a good idea
yeah that's a good idea i'm very stephen
i gotta run
okay and my services the bus are needed
thank you all very much i guess i'll
talk to you again
uh on another occasion in the near
future sounds good
no but but look so i'm going to complain
about this right
it's like we've got a style this isn't
following it
and you know again the style is
there's explanatory text there's a
caption that ends with a colon
then there's a piece of code and that's
you know that's the thing now you could
rewrite this
easily enough um you know you know it
needs positioning statement
i mean look why don't we just take this
form and try and reframe some things in
this form
and you know now one thing maybe
maybe what we want to add so let me just
remind you and again
so over time here um the the i'm going
to remind you about one other thing
okay about exposition which is the eiwl
effort okay so so one of the things that
was in the iwl
and again this is the stuff we have to
invent shoddy in particular
this is this is sort of uh for you i
mean
if i look at eiwl here um i've got
the main text which is very much the
paragraph
caption code caption code blah blah blah
blah
okay now what i invented for this was
this vocabulary section i don't know how
successful that's been
that sort of a summary exercise is okay
that was weird but
okay q a was another important section
and then tech notes okay
so the point of tech notes is you know
one thing you do might do as you're
writing your main text
is like you keep on looking over your
shoulders saying but what about an
expert they're gonna tell me this isn't
right
well then you can have something like
tech notes at the end
which is okay you're an expert look you
know the author was not as clueless as
you thought
and when you say are they really talking
about this
then you know that is telling them that
so to speak
um and similarly this q a
uh it's like you know answer the obvious
questions we haven't done this in
documentation
we could consider it i don't know don't
know if it's a good idea
but i found this super helpful in
writing the iwl book because there were
there were just
so many things where okay color negation
right so i probably have a thing up here
that um uh
color negate quotes negates a color
giving the complementary color
okay so you might reasonably ask what on
earth does that really mean
you know uh you know somebody yo the
expert is looking over your shoulder
shoddy roger other people here know
perfectly well that color negation
depends on the color space
right so the expert looking over your
shoulder is going to say what are you
talking about
but you don't have to worry about that
because you can you know that's enough
for the typical person
you can go down to the tech notes where
it's like okay what do they mean by
color negation
well you know whatever here we go
and and um uh okay are there ways to
specify colors other than rgb
okay there i mean that that's that's
again
you know some kind of explanatory thing
so i don't know i mean
my point is for these essays we have to
expositions we have to invent some
devices like this
and that's you know we've been very
successful in documentation
it's lasted 30 something years you know
the devices that we have for
documentation
you know there are different devices to
be invented for these other things
this is an example you know see what
seems to fit i mean here
i invented these devices because i was
getting stuck i was like i don't know
what to do about this i've got a
technical point do i put a footnote
you know how does this work um
all right the um and people are
commenting here that we should have a
style guide online and i agree if we get
this properly
straightened out um uh
the um uh that we should um
uh we should codify it properly i agree
and i think it'd be useful
we do have some stuff for people writing
patlet documentation don't we
people using the new documentation tools
do we have that andre
well i think we had we'd certainly
implicitly in the tools we'd written
some of that stuff
yeah but i don't know how much of it is
absolutely there waiting for a packlet
update
um fair enough okay we need to go to
this other meeting i apologize to
and you can bring it up in the meeting
you have to go to yes i understand
um all right well thanks and thanks to
folks on the live stream and we will
continue into another one of these
because i think this is going to be
useful and next time
the deliverables from the next meeting
will be the actual and people can come
with a
set of suggestions for what our sort of
style guide is that will be very helpful
um and and talking about what our types
of documents are going to be
and what the style guides are for those
types of documents
okay okay all right see you guys soon